Elon Musk released his statement
explaining Twitter purchase quote it is
important to the future of civilization
to have a common digital Town Square
where a range of beliefs can be debated
in a healthy manner without resorting to
violence and of course he is correct
um you know he said some some
interesting things there that he's he's
trying to bring people together and I
think Elon might be a little bit naive
let me tell you guys a story I recently
went to um
I was in Texas and I got to meet with a
bunch of people including uh some
confidants and Associates of Elon I
guess I'm there's a party and so people
who were there claim to know him I don't
know but there were a lot of influential
people there who worked in the tech
sector and it was a big Tech sector
thing and then I just I was there and I
said to my I was I was talking to some
friends and I was like I don't think
these guys understand culture at all
they very much understand technology and
that's probably why Elon wanted to buy
Twitter in the first place because he
understands its power but he does not
understand the left he really doesn't I
think he's relatively new to this so
Aiden paladin on Twitter I saw this
great thing that she had posted numerous
studies show that inherent in the left
explicitly and overtly it is dominated
by greed violence Envy hatred and
there's numerous studies that she cited
in this post showing all of these
scientific studies about how that's
where they're rooted I'm not surprised
because we get fake news we get
manipulation we get lying cheating
stealing it's remarkable when when uh
when a commercial played today I'm
skating we have the radio on well we
have Pandora on and they just they're
lying about Dr Oz and I'm like look I
don't like Oz but just it's all lies you
know why the defamation lawsuit cost of
doing business to win an election you
lie about your opponent you win the
packs got to pay a fee that's just part
of the part of the process I don't think
Elon Musk understands the bifurcation of
culture and where this ultimately will
lead to but I will say when it comes to
this escalating conflict the right
continually being like we will let the
left speak we just want to speak to and
we don't want to fight we want peaceful
divorce that's when you get crushed yeah
when you have two sides fighting and or
or really when you have two groups and
and I know that there's sort of been
this
description of American societies left
versus right left versus right left
versus right and I don't think that's
correct I don't actually think that's
right at all I think there's the left I
think there's the right and in the
middle you have normies I oh hold on and
no certainly there's other groups out
there it's a spectrum Etc but normies
are the people who are like not focused
on politics not focused on news 24 7
they're not the junkies they're not
going in for that dopamine fix on
Twitter on YouTube whatever all the time
and so the question is are the normies
getting more and more radicalized or not
are they getting are they paying
attention are they getting red pilled
but then when you have one group that
says we are going to destroy you and
change all of culture to fit our needs
and fit our culture and our precepts and
another side that says hey we just want
to be left alone then it's pretty
obvious which side's gonna win I I want
to just I don't I don't know if it's
left right nor me I used to think that
now what I think happened is you have
the left and the right and then a weird
growth on the left started to Bubble Up
and then schlocked off and has become
this weird
unhinged hateful chaotic destructive
force that thinks it's the left and then
looks at the normal world of Left Right
and moderate as right wing that's why
everyone to the right of Stalin is far
right they called did you see Jezebel
called the Ian Crossland a conservative
commentator I mean he's just the most
conservative guy I mean he's always here
demanding traditional marriage telling
people to stop getting divorced yeah you
need to raise that baby no no they
mistakenly uh they were referring to a
quote from Sheamus but just the fact
that they they didn't even realize the
mistake I mean all white people look
alike so I to them I suppose but I think
about that I think about when they say
like Tim Poole is far right and I'm like
it's just so weird that I'm like this
traditional liberal and you know like
Jack you're conservative Luke's you're
an anarchist Alex I believe you're
conservative too and we're having civil
discussion with moderate American
culture styled disagreements in in the
space and agreements and whatever this
weird left that sloft off
just doesn't believe in anything at all
and the Democrats try to Pander to that
that you you're it's like it's a sludge
it's also it's also that it's not that
they don't believe in anything it's that
that what they believe is not a
political ideology what they believe is
a form of political theocracy
yeah the sludge also is so effective
because they move together and they're
always the loudest people in the rooms
they're always there to they're the mop
and they try to shout you down it's fire
and and beat you up and Elon is facing
that daily now on Twitter uh you know
before look at the photos you saw the
photos right when he went to see when he
went to visit Twitter today the woman's
face yeah and you can see the the people
that he's talking to right whoever he's
making eye contact with and you can see
because there were a variety of photos
that came out not just this one I was I
haven't seen any videos yet which is
weird like why do we have photos but not
video and whenever he's making eye
contact with someone he's a Charming guy
obviously he's very personable
um they're super nice but then when he
turns you always get these photos behind
like yeah I mean I think it's also
important to assess here that Elon Musk
did buy Twitter because of what you guys
are describing there's a meeting going
around today of uh uh The Dominoes
falling and one of them is the Babylon
bee calling a man a man being a very
small Domino right and then the very big
Domino at the end is Elon Musk walking
into Twitter headquarters with a kitchen
sink in his hands good yeah so so I I
think I think the letter to advertisers
that Elon Musk wrote Today is extremely
telling he wrote about how he was doing
this for Humanity he wrote about how big
Tech social media is bifurcating
splintering people to the far left and
the far right he talked about Echo
Chambers he talks about how he wants to
help Humanity with this purchase as this
letter looks like he's laying the
groundwork for allowing people that were
previously deleted back on the platform
which is going to create some
controversy it looks like he's trying to
save face from the controversy it looks
like he's setting up a situation where
he's like making the argument for
bringing back free speeches no no no no
no hold on a minute it's been reported
that he closed the deal yeah he's in
Twitter HQ
why isn't James O'Keefe back on the
platform no no hold on I know everyone
immediately says Tim Alex Jones Donald
Trump I'm like I understand all of those
those are political arguments the
argument with say Jones and with Trump
and Carl Benjamin uh is you know oh well
uh hate speech or whatever and then we
roll our eyes and say that's ridiculous
James O'Keefe broke no rules
they didn't even what was it they said
he was operating multiple accounts for
some fake reason I think they did the
same thing to Milo as well like the
first thing Elon should have done when
he walked in
is said like okay we we seriously need
to like Veritas back on the platform
yeah well I I have a feeling it's going
to look a lot like the Pokemon movie
when like all of the Pokemon like turned
to stone and then Ash starts crying and
you know all of a sudden the Pokemon
come back to life that's what Twitter's
gonna be the first time I've ever heard
anyone actually make a Pokemon movie the
Pokemon well that's what it's gonna be
it's gonna be an awesome scene
everyone's gonna be moved to tears from
Narnia isn't that the end of Lion The
Witch in the wardrobe I don't know this
this movie came out they might have you
know they might have but it was in the
1940s yeah and then uh and then Mewtwo
I'm not a historian Jack and then Mewtwo
says I understand now the circumstances
of one's birth does not define you okay
okay exactly stop nerding out wait here
let's talk about disease
or is Alex Jones Mewtwo no I think James
O'Keefe is like probably the guy just
standing there filming what's going on
they kicked out
he's the camera guy from Jack dorsey's
Mewtwo no that's both no that's Pokemon
Snap that's different stop it stop it
going on here now now TMZ is reporting
that that Elon Musk is officially uh a
buyer of Twitter but from the reports
that I'm looking at right now the bank
accounts are still sending the money uh
to all the people that are the
shareholders they're still in the
process of that I didn't get paid and
you know where's my money
for doing rash things but I think in
this huge billion dollar investment that
that is taking away a quarter of his
entire wealth I think he's going to be
smart but also slow I think he's going
to be looking at what happened looking
at each case individually and and I
think if anyone's going to be reinstated
first I think it's going to be the
Babylon bee
I I I think you know so I have 22 shares
with Twitter and I see the price at like
54 bucks now it's like 53 or something
they're they're delisting it from the
New York Stock Exchange which basically
confirms the deals done and uh Elon I
want my money where's my money I'll tell
you what
I will only accept the money in the form
of you coming here personally and
sitting down and then you know handing
the cash while the show is on of course
so so tomorrow at 8pm uh eastern time is
the only time I'm accepting the cash
there's a love to see you there's a line
and I'm gonna paraphrase it from
Machiavelli's the prince
um you know 500 years old but everybody
remembers it where he says that if a
prince must commit atrocities he should
commit them early
[Laughter]
and and so I always kind of think of
that that Elon has this sort of period
right now where what I'm calling for
don't do this piecemeal this like set up
some system of well we'll do this one
we'll do Babylon we'll do no blanket
amnesty yeah
overturn every single permanent ban on
Twitter make everyone when they come
back they hold on hold on they have to
redo their terms of service they have to
sign up again they have to go through
the process they have to follow it but
my point is release the release the
prisoners of war from the great meme war
of 2015 2016 immediately let my people
go hold on hold on there's a challenge
there there are a lot of accounts that
were permanently banned for things we
would agree they should be banned for
like graphic images of kids or uh uh
well you set up a system where if if
it's not something that's directly
criminal for example uh as Elon has said
if it's on the First Amendment then I'm
going to let it all I I do think they're
uh
I I agree mostly I do I just think it
has to be it can't be a blanket it has
to be a probably a large analysis they
need to be able to go and look at
however they went about banning them and
like if anyone banned for saying learn
to code reinstated instantly well for
example we already know and he hates
speech ban we know through the Missouri
lawsuit with uh A.G Schmidt that they
were Banning people at the behest of the
NIH they were Banning people on the
behest of uh the White House California
the White House
um DC Drano got banned because the state
of California we know that
um let's see what I'm thinking of Alec
Berenson Alec Berenson was able to get
his account back because he pointed out
the Twitter instituted this three-strike
law for covid-19 and then they didn't
even follow their own three strikes
which also gets to my point because
that's contract law that right you need
to fix the terms of service thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there